rewrite the radical expression using
rational exponents and to simplify so
here we have the fourth root of five a
to the fourth B to the 12th power and
the key thing to realize here is the
fourth root of something is the same
thing as that something to the 1/4 power
or in particular the or in general the
nth root of something is the same thing
as that something to the one over N
power so we can just apply that over
here the fourth root of all of this is
equal to five a to the fourth B to the
twelfth power all of that to the 1/4
power and then we also know if we take
the product of things and then raise
them to some exponent that's the same
thing as raising each of the terms in
the product to the exponent first or
each of the things that we're taking the
product of to that exponent and then and
then multiplying so let's do that so
five so this is the same thing as five
to the one fourth power times a to the
fourth to the one fourth power times B
to the 12th to the one fourth power now
five to the one fourth I don't know what
that is
so I'll just keep that as the cube root
well we could leave it as five to the
one fourth and that's not not simplified
or we could just rewrite it again as the
fourth root fourth root of five a to the
fourth to the one fourth power if you
raise something to a power and then
another power and raise that to another
power that's the equivalent of raising
the a to the four times one fourth power
so let me just write that down this is
so times a to the four times one fourth
power
and then finally this right over here
using the same exact exponent property
this is B to the 12th times one fourth
power and so all of this simplifies to
and I'll change the order here so you
have the Q the fourth root the fourth
root of five and then you have a to the
fourth times one fourth power so that's
just this simplifies to a to the first
power which is really just the same
thing as a so that's just a and then we
have B to the twelve times 1/12 times
one fourth
our well 12 times one fourth is just
three so that's B to the third power so
it's a B to the third power times the
fourth root of five